hey guys smash from axe Tech I want to
let you know that this review is gonna
be a bit different from my previous ones
yes I am gonna harp on the pixel for for
its obvious shortcomings along with some
other not so obvious ones I'm also gonna
let you know why this pixel 4 is my
favorite pixel yet and along with that
why you most likely should not buy one
but by a pixel 3a instead now Google did
send us this pixel 4 so thank you google
for sending it out but I have to be
completely honest and saying that I
really can't understand what the pixel
team at Google is doing everybody that I
know that uses a pixel is really loyal
to the brand and very hopeful for their
future most of them want similar things
but it seems like Google isn't listening
they keep taking these big risks trying
new things and hoping that something
will stick when they could just ask the
community what they want and deliver it
it's no secret that this phone is
overpriced compared to the competition
maybe Google has a price at that high
due to the solely sensor that I found
fairly unreliable or maybe the R&D that
they put in or just keep up appearances
as a flagship design wise it seems like
a copy of the earlier iPhone 11 renders
especially the camera bump but on the
front we have these uneven bezels that
don't look as nice and least in my
opinion now I personally do like the
iPhone clone look but I wish they would
have just stuck with the previous
two-tone design of the previous pixels
which i think looks more unique and fits
in with the brand then looking like
something a bit more generic spec wise
in my opinion it is no longer a flagship
with android competitors being so good
offering way better battery life faster
charging more RAM and storage much
better displays and more hardware wise
Google made a few big changes that I
personally like but I think most pixel
fans would have done something different
the biggest one is ditching their
convenient rear mounted fingerprint
scanner for a similar array of face
unlock sensors like in the iPhone but
adding that radar sensor and thus having
a large forehead you know I don't like
the outdated look but I love the
convenience of face and lock especially
with software that allows it to
instantly go to the home screen which is
the best thing about this phone being
someone who loves a 50 millimeter lens
on a real camera I really love having a
telephoto lens but
even still I don't think it makes sense
for them to add one after all at the
talk of one lens being enough and if we
can only have two lenses I definitely
think it would make much more sense
going for an ultra wide lens because
it's much more useful in a lot of
situations you can't back up to get a
shot but it's just impossible where you
can always digitally zoom in to grab
something that's further away I love the
fact that they added a 90 Hertz screen
but when using it in the real world I
was a bit disappointed because it seemed
like the phone is choosing 60 Hertz the
majority of the time and it turns out
that it actually does do that and that's
a save battery life now the batteries
and these phones aren't huge and
efficiency isn't great either with the
Excel version getting around five to
five and a half hours of screen on time
in just over four hours if you force 90
Hertz in the developer settings I can't
imagine how bad the battery life is on
the standard pixel 4 that has a much
smaller battery after many years Apple
finally listened to its community and
put a larger battery in the 11pro and
everybody loved it Google why can't you
do the same it seems like you keep being
a year behind the competition why not
take the biggest complaints about the
pixel 3 and focus on fixing those
instead of changing your mind about
previous design choices and adding new
features that nobody really asked for
why not stick with that super resume on
the standard lens that most people are
happy with and give us an ultra wide
lens instead
ELISA 4000 milliamp hour battery ditched
that bathtub notch for a 2019
appropriate teardrop notch or maybe a
cutout give us 128 gigabytes of base
storage and eight gigabytes of RAM so
Ram management wouldn't even cross our
minds the last thing that they really
needed is a brighter OLED display this
one only gets up to an abysmal 448 nits
this makes it very difficult to see
outside compared to other 2019 flagships
that range between a thousand to 1300
nits and in fact the $400 pixel 3 A's
display is actually slightly brighter
maybe Google is just limiting it because
of battery life but this is not
acceptable for a flagship in 2019 for
most Android users the pixel force
Hardware is not that tempting especially
for the price and for older pixel owners
most of the
new software will be available soon for
download in fact the camera app is
already ported so you can download it
right now on the older devices now they
could have made the pixel for stand out
more from the other pixels say maybe
finally focusing on video performance
but nope still no 4k 60 apparently
because of lack of space or even 1080p
60 on the front-facing camera the video
quality is still really poor with it
using a very limiting rec 601 color
profile which doesn't make sense because
that was put out before HD video was
released and on to photo quality other
than the astrophotography mode which is
amazing and by the way can be downloaded
right now for other devices the rest
really falls flat image quality isn't
bad but Google is no longer leading the
pack with the iPhone 11 beating it in
most shots and the note 10 being better
and many as well but having an advantage
of the ultra lens and way more
flexibility in software we actually did
a detailed comparison video with a pixel
3a XL which is less than half the price
of the pixel 4 and most of the photos
were almost identical we mostly noticed
more accurate white balance and contrast
which are all software related updates
that will come to the pixel 3/8 in fact
the actual sensor that captures images
is the same exact sensor that is in the
pixel 3 and the pixel 3a so they are way
behind the competition when it comes to
sensor performance now Google is still
trying to make the most out of its 2016
sensor but it really shows since its
images have visible noise and
artifacting and shadow details the
software is clearly great I just wonder
how much better it would be if they took
the money that they spent on the radar
and put it towards the latest camera
sensors from Sony and for some more
problems with the cameras you are forced
into a 1.5 x crop in portrait mode while
other phones let you capture wide shots
and even though we have the new
telephoto lens it is not even used for
portrait mode shots instead it uses the
standard lens with digital zoom which
means lower detail and portraits
especially if you compare them to
iPhones new diffusion panoramas are
still very low quality and for some
reason the pixel 4 takes slightly longer
to process portrait shots then the pixel
3a which has a much
we core processor and no neural course
now even with all of these complaints I
do have to say that I actually enjoyed
using the pixel for I love it's slimmer
6.3 inch display that makes it much more
comfortable in the hand and I really
liked the new stock Android 10 gestures
and of course the new face unlock
feature this leads me to who the pixel 4
is perfect for the first group is for
those that really don't care about value
or having the best hardware but more of
the software experience and the second
group is for those who are using an
older iPhone and want to switch to an
Android this phone is the closest
Android to an iPhone ever from the look
of it the feel the face unlock the
gestures the ambient display adjustments
the limited specs for the price and much
more and in all honesty the pixel 4 is
like an Android version of the iPhone 10
from 2017 high prices similar
performance low 64 gigabytes of storage
Ram that is just barely enough dual
cameras now it's surprisingly similar
colors to the iPhone and Jolla display
that is a bit too dim in direct sunlight
similar poor battery life but with a
great software experience the thing is
that Apple released that comparable
iPhone 2 years ago so if you care about
value or flagship specs in 2019 the
pixel 4 isn't for you now on the other
hand if you don't care about specs and
you just want a great software
experience with good photos how would
you say by a pixel 3 axl yes the build
quality isn't as nice it does have a
weaker processor and it's missing a few
features like wireless charging but the
software experience and photo and video
quality are almost identical and the
display is brighter the fingerprint
sensor works great and the battery life
is way better for less than half the
price and of course you get a headphone
jack if you care about that
so overall the pixel 4 has the great
software experience great phrase
unlocking that is convenient but it's
more of a mid tier phone instead of a
flagship for a flagship price with kind
of poor battery life and if that's ok
for you you may be happy with it but I
think most people should look elsewhere
either a oneplus maybe an iPhone
or a Samsung or just wait another year
for the pixel 5 and hopefully Google
listens to its community and focuses on
what people really care about thank you
guys for watching this been max with max
that click above to subscribe and down
below to enable notifications don't
forget to check out our comparison for
photos and videos compared to the pixel
3/8 right over there
[Music]